il y a un des collègues ici qui n'est
pas là qui hier me disait que ça
ressemblait un peu au jour sans fin
c'està-dire entre le lundi et le
mercredi ça ressemblé avec Pierre
muscovici après Bruno Le Maire qu'on va
retrouver je trouvais que c'était cétait
assez exact
euh et donc on va dire ça comme ça mais
le jour ressemble pas mal bien
euh donc c'est du coup la deuxième
occasion que nous avons de recevoir
devant notre commission cette semaine en
sa qualité de président du Haut Conseil
des finances publiques Monsieur Pierre
Moscovici afin qu'il nous présente
l'avis qui a rendu le Haut conseil sur
les projets de loi de finances et de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2024 qui euh vient d'être présenté
il y a quelques heures à Bery devant la
presse euh comme vous le savez l' viis
du ha conseil porte sur les prévisions
macro-économiques qui font le PLF et le
PLFSS ainsi que sur la cohérence entre
l'article liminire du PLF et du PLFSS et
les orientations pluannuel de soldes
structurels fixés par l're programmation
par ailleurs le Haut Conseil doit
également donner son avis sur sur le
réalisme des prévisions de recettes et
de dépenses du PLF et du PLFSS euh je
préside cette réunion mais euh Véronique
louvagi me succédera tout à l'heure je
l' remercie monsieur le Président du
Conseil vous avez la
parole merci Monsieur le le le président
monsieur le rapporteur général mesdames
et messieurs les députés
euh je me réjoui de de revenir
aujourd'hui devant votre commission en
tant que président du Conseil des
finances publiques pour vous présenter
cette fois les principales conclusions
de notre avis relatif au projet de loi
de finance et de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour l' 2024 je pense
quand même que dans les semaines et mois
qui viennent vous aurez beaucoup plus
l'occasion de voir Bruno Le Maire et
Thomas casenav que moi sauf si pro
finance rectificative est déposé tous
les jours mais ce ne sera pas le cas
donc je suis là pour non pas seul de
tout compte mais pour un petit moment ce
sera la dernière fois le projet de loi
de programmation des finances publiques
sur lequel nous avons
eu l'occasion d'échanger en effet
déterminer la trajectoire nos finances
publicqu d'ici 2027 et cet avis du
conseil que je vous présente aujourd'hui
examine la première brique il va de soi
c'est logique que la crédibilité de
l'ensemble dépend de la pose de cette
première pierre conformément à la loi
organique du 28 décembre 2021 le Conseil
a été non seulement saisi des prévisions
macroéconomiques mais il a également
porté une appréciation sur le réalisme
des prévisions de recettes et dépenses
des pro de finance et de financement de
la sécurité sociale je veux signaler une
fois n'est pas coutume que pour
accomplir sa mission le Haut Conseil a
bénéficié en réponse à sa demande en ce
sens d'un enrichissement des
informations sur les finances publiques
qui ont été transmises par
l'administration et même de délais
presque convenable puisque nous avons
une semaine donc les chos s'améliore de
ce point de vue-là et vous ne trouvez
pas notre traditionnelle remarque
deumeur médiocre sur ces sujets je me
félicite en tout cas de la qualité de
ces échanges car nous pouvons ainsi
mieux jouer notre rôle au service du
Parlement et des citoyens j'eviens
aux deux principaux messages assez
simples de notre avis euh premièrement
le scén MACR du gouvernement pour 2024
repospothèse de croissance de 1,4 % que
le Conseil estime élevé et deuxièmement
la prévision d'un sol public de 4,4
points de PIB paraît quant à elle
optimiste les deux choses étant
naturellement liées j'entre maintenant
dans le détail de ces deux messages
rapide retour peut-être pour commencer
sur la situation économique
internationale la croissance de
l'économie mondiale après avoir fabli en
2023 resterait globalement un changer en
2024 elle serait pénalisée par une
inflation cert en baisse mais toujours
élevé par des politiques monétaires
durablement restrictives au sein des
pays développés l'environnement
économique mondial devrait rester peu
porteur pour la croissance française et
nos finances publiques aux États-Unis en
dépit du relèvement des taux par la f au
rythme le plus rapide obseré depuis 40
ans la croissance a mieux résisté c'est
vrai qu'anticipé en 2023 la hausse de
l'emploi l'inflation ont soutenu la
croissance du revenu réel des ménages et
donc leur consommation tiré en outre par
une forte baisse du taux d'épargne
l'ampleur du soutien budgétaire en
faveur des infrastructures et de la
réindustrialisation a également stimulé
l'investissement la dégradation en cours
de la situation financière des ménages
qui ont largement puisé dans leur
épargne accumulé P la crise sanitaire
pour nourrir le consommation ainsi que
le recerrement monétaire devrait
cependant peser sur la croissance
américaine en 2024 les prévisions que la
croissance américaine devrait ralentir
significativement même si ce pays
devrait éviter la récession quand au
rebond la croissance chinoise qui a
suivi la levée des restrictions liées à
la fin de la politique de zéro covid il
s'est révélé de courte durée les
inquiétudes sur la situation du secteur
immobilier la situation de l'emploi pèse
sur les dépenses des ménages et des
entreprises qui ont eu tendance à
privilégier eux contrairement aux
Américains l'augmentation de leur taux
d'épargne et le désendettement de sur
quoi on a ce que vous connaissez tous
c'est des tensions
géopolitiques qui se sont traduit par
une chute des investissements étrangers
et affaiblissement des
exportations l'évolution récente des
prix la consommation le surendettement
de certains acteurs majeurs de
l'immobilier ainsi que des Collectiv
local devrait continuer de apeser sur
l'économies chinoise dans les trimestres
à venir d'autant que les autorités son
peu encline à stimuler la croissance et
donc c'est un facteur d'incertitude
parallèlement les économies de la zone
euro notre environnement proche traverse
une phase de ralentissement les
indicateurs publiés durant l'été signal
que l'activité se pourrait contracter
dans plusieurs P européen la hausse des
taux de la Banque centrale européenne de
450 points de base depuis juillet 2022
aect progressivement les économies de la
zone euro la demande de crédit a chuté
en lien avec la hausse des taux
d'intérêt entraînant une diminution des
investissements une dégradation du
marché immobilier nous n sommes pas
comme vous savez préservés en Allemagne
en particulier les perspectives sont
nettement assombres pour les prochains
mois les différents institut conjoncture
prévoient une contraction du PIB sur
l'ensemble de 2023 notamment du fait de
l'industrie toutefois le retour de la
croissance devrait intervenir en
Allemagne en 2024 mais elle reste très
modeste et sur une base dégradée
comprise entre 1 et 13 % selon les
prévisions
disponibles l'activité allemande serait
tirée par rebond de la consommation
grâce à la conjonction de forte hausse
de salaire et du recul de l'inflation
qui redonnerait du pouvoir d'achat au
ménage bien sûr les prévisions que je
donne sont marquées par beaucoup
d'incertitude les tensions géopolitiques
la poursuite du conflit en Ukraine on ne
sait pas ce qui va se passer sur les
prix du pétrole ils sont passé de 80
dollars à la fin juillet 90 dollars à la
mi-septembre suite à la décision de
l'OPEP de restreindre son offre de
pétrole par la la vitesse et l'ampleur
du replil de l'inflation qui je le
rappelle conditionne la trajectoire à
avenir des taux d'intérêt des banques C
centrale demeure incertaine de même que
la densité et la gravité des effets de
la hausse des taux déjà effectués sur la
croissance et l'inflation qui est assez
incertaine enfin les risques sanitaires
n'ont pas totalement disparu même s'ils
ontement
ref dans ce contexte j'en viens aux
observations du Haut conseil sur les
prévisions macroéc du gouvernement vous
les connaissez en vérité mais j'avais
promis de les détailler il y a de jours
j'y viens nous considérons que le taux
de croissance retenu pour l'économie
française en 2024 est élevé en revanche
nous estimons que la prévision
d'inflation 2,6 % et masse salariale
sont quant elle
plausible je vrais rappeler que au-delà
des nombreuses alléas que je viens de
mentionner l'exercice de la prévision
économique appelle plus que jamais à
beaucoup de modestie l'évolution
actuelle de certains comportement
économi comme le tauxp desménage il est
élevé
aujourd'hui pourquoi la faiblesse
durable de la productivité tout ça c'est
très difficile à comprendre pour tout le
monde les hypothèses sur leur
persistance qui auraient des effets au
contraire sur un retour à la normale
diffèr fortement selon les
prévisionnistes que le Haut Conseil
auditionné or c'est un impact majeur sur
les prévisions économiques qui sont
effectues s'agissant de la croissance du
PIB elle s'établirait selon le S du
gouvernement à 1 % en 2023 et 14 en 2024
pour 2023 vous savez que l'économie
l'activité économique au 2e trimestre en
France en hausse de 0,5 en rythme
trimestriel a été plus soutenu
qu'anticipé beaucoup plus soutenu
qu'anticipé portant l'Aquis de
croissance à 0,8 à la fin du premer
semestre disons que l'économie française
depuis semble être rentrée dans une
phase de ralentissement le resserrement
de la politique monétaire commence à se
faire sentir au-delà du secteur
immobilier qui comme vous le savez d'ors
et déjà est très fortement affecté les
informations conjoncturelles disponible
sur le 3e trimestre monte un
fléchissement des anticipations des
chats d'entreprise une confiance des
ménages qui peinent à se redresser
la prévision du gouvernement d'une
croissance de 1 % en 2023 équivalente
par exemple à celle de la Commission
européenne reste cependant plausible car
une croissance trimestrielle légèrement
positive sur les deux derniers
trimestres est suffisante pour
l'atteindre en revanche pour 2024 la
prévision de gouvernance s'écarte
nettement de celle des autresintitut de
prévision elle est légèrement supérieure
à celle de la Commission européenne 1,2
% de l'OCDE 1,2%
du FMI 1,3 % notons quand même que ces
deux dernières datent de près de 3 mois
elle est supérieure à celle du consensus
des économist de septembre 0,8
% la fourchette est comprise entre 0,3
et 1,3 %
elle est supérieure à celle de tous les
prévisionnistes auditionnés par le Haut
Conseil très divers code oFCE
lesentations sont pas les mêmes et
surtout de la Banque de France qui est
quand même une institution qui a
conviendrait relativement pignon sur rue
ces estimations sont entre 0,4 et 0,9
1,4 c'est donc fortement
supérieur il nous semble que les
hypothèses du gouvernement sont fragiles
elles supposent le durcissement que le
durcissement des conditions de crédit
aura un impact limité sur
l'investissement des entreprises en
2024 que contrairement au prévision
desintitut auditionné par le Conseil le
durcissement du crédit entraînera un
recul beaucoup plus faible de
l'investissement des ménages en 2024 20
23 et donc oui nous disons que c'est
élevé même si nous reconnaissons que
compte tenu des nombreuses incertitudes
qui affect toute prévision pour 2024 ce
n'est pas
inatteignable mais comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire devant votre
commission il y a 2 jours le fait
qu'elle soit éventuellement atteignable
ne signifie pas pourtant et ça doit-être
votre critère que c'est une bonne base
pour construire une loi de
finance les informations
disponibles ne conduisent pas en général
prévoir 1,4 % et donc le Haut Conseil le
dit concernant l'inflation maintenant la
progression de l'indice des prix àation
sera 4,9 % en moyenne en 2023 sur le
gouvernement ce qui est
plausible pour
2024 sous une hypothèse de 86,1 milliard
de dollars pour le baril l'inflation est
prévue à 2,6 % moyenne annuelle le
replilis de la hausse des prix
alimentaires manufur se poursuivrait
tandis que le prix des services
progresserait à r plus élevé que celui
constaté avant la crise sanitaire du
fait des Hauses de salaires plus
dynamique au total le Conseil estime que
cette prévision est elle aussi
plausible comme pour 2023 il nous semble
toutefois qu'elle est affectée d'un
risque de dépassement lié notamment à la
hausse récente du prix du pétrole le
Haut Conseil consid également que la
prévision de masse salariale pour 2023
2024 est plausible je récapitule donc
notre avis sur les prévisions macro du
gouvernement pour
2024 une prévision de croissance élevée
même si des incertitudes demeurent
une prévision d'inflation crédible avec
toutefois des risques de dépassement des
prévisions d'emploi et de masse
salariale
plausible et j'en viens maintenant aux
prévisions sur les finances publiques le
C du gouvernement prévoit un solde
public effectif de 4,9 points négatif en
2023 et 4,4 en
2024 la prévision de sold pour 2023
n'appelle pas de remarque 4,9 n semble
plausible celle pour 2024 nous paraît
conjugué principalement des hypothèses
favorable tant du côté des recettes que
des dépenses et pourrait être pourrait
être surestimé détaillant d'abord plus
précisément les prévisions d'évolution
des recettes en 2023 les prélement
obligatoires augmenteraient selon le
gouvernement de 3,7 % pour atteindre
1241 milliards l'évolution des recettes
de PR obligatoire en 2023 refléterait
une croissance spontanée de 4 %
sensiblement inférieure à celle du PIB
en valeur se traduisant par une
élasticité des des recettes nettement
inférieur à l'unité après de annéesti
parement élevé laaly des principaux
impôts ne fait pas ressortir de biens
importants en
2024 la prévision de PO sera 1292
milliards d'euros soit 4,1 % par 2023
elle est très proche de celle du PIB en
valeur les mesures nouvelles viendraient
amputer les recettes de prélement
obligatoire à hauteur de 1,5 milliards
d'euros cette prévision paraît haute
notamment du fait d'une hypothèse de
croissance de l'activité elle même
optimiste c'est hein 0,5 points de
croissance en plus ou en moins ça fait
02 points de déficit en plus ou en moins
et donc 4,4 est calé sur
0,5 plus que le consensus des
prévisionnist ce billet affecte plus
particulièrement les préements
obligatoires dont les assiettes sont les
plus corréés au PIB en particulier la
TVA l'impôt sur les société au-delà de
l'impact de l'hypothèse de croissance la
prévision de PO était aussi tirée par
des hypothèses favorables sur sur le
rendement de certains impôts avec
notamment une croissance prévue de la
TVA supérieure à celle de sa base
taxable et un arrêt prévu de la baisse
des droits de mutation à titre pour
résumer nos observations sur les
recettes je dirais qu'elles nous
paraissent un peu surestimé je passe
maintenant à l'évolution des dépenses
publiques en 2023 les dépenses publiques
hors crédit d'impôt augmenteraient de
3,4 % en valeur pour s'élever à 55,9
points de PIB contre 57,7 % en 2022 en
volume elle refluerait de 1,3 % ce qui
résulte de la quasi extinction des
dépenses lié à la crise sanitaire cette
fois-ci quoi qu'il en coûte enfin serait
fini de la baisse du coût des mesures
liées à l'inflation au dépenses de
relance ainsi une fois ces dépenses
exclues les dépenses publiques
augmenteraient de 5,4 % en valeur et de
0,5 % en volume en 2024 les dépenses
augmenteraient de 3 % en valeur et de
0,5 en volume la progression serait
cependant nettement plus sensible une
fois neutralisé les mesures
exceptionnelles de soutien
elle atteindrait 4,8 % en valeur et 2,2
% en volume il convient de noter qu'en
2024 le poids des dépenses publiques
dans le PIB serait encore supérieur de
1,5 points à ce qu'il était avant la
crise sanitaire 55,3 contre 53,8 en 2019
j'aimerais souligner ici que sur le
nouveau champ dit périmètre des dépenses
de l'État la très forte réduction du
coût des mesures de soutien face à la
hausse des prix de l'énergie serait
presque compensé par la Haus rés des
priorités gouvernementales les politiqu
en faveur de la transition énergétique
ou écologique de 7 milliard d'euros les
mesures d'attractivité pour l'éducation
nationale plus 3,1 milliard d'euros les
politiques sectorielles qui font l'objet
de crédit supplémentaes inscrit dans une
n programmation défense justice
recherche et intérieure enfin la charge
des intérêts de l'État augmentera en
2024 par rapport à 2023 de près de 10
milliards d'euros en comptabilité
nationale cette prévision de hausse des
dépenses publiques est sujette selon
nous à plusieurs facteur de dépassement
d'abord le coût du bouclier tarifaire
sur les prix de l'électricité maintenu
en 2024 est fortement dépendant des prix
à venir sur les marchés de gros et son
coût paraît faible au vu des prix
observés au cours des derniers mois
d'autre part le gouvernement prévoit un
net ralentissement des dépenses de santé
sous onâ 3,2 % après 4,8 ce qui suppose
un inflement un inflchissement de la
tendance spontanée des soins de ville
qui semble optimiste et un volet
d'économie de 3,5 milliards d'euros qui
est costau un tel montant d'économie a
déjà été atteint par le passé mais il
paraît sensible complexe à réaliser dans
un contexte de tension notamment dans le
secteur hospitalier et sur l'offre de
mic par conséquent les dépenses
publiques pourrai s'avérer plus élevé
que prévu notamment s'agissant du coût
des dispositifs énergétiques et des
dépenses de santé au total il ressort de
cette analyse par le Conseil des
recettes et des dépenses ce qui est
notre rôle que la prévision de dépenses
publiqu qui vous sera présentée pour
4,4 n'est pas inatteignable là encore
mais estre optimiste enfin j'en termine
par là où je l'ai fait sur la LPFP
concernant la dette publique le ratio de
dette publique diminuerait de 2 points
en 2023 à 109,7 points de PIB grâce à
une croissance du PIB en valeur forte 6
% il ne baisserait plus en 2024 la
croissance du pb en valeur sera encore
forte mais retrouvera une valeur plus
proche des évolutions des 20 dernières
années je conclus disant que 2024 sera
une année charnière pour nos finances
publiques notre déficit public demeure
toujours sensiblement supérieur à la
limite de tris points de pb prévus par
les r du PCT de stabilité il se ralentit
lentement or comme vous le savez la
Commission a annoncé que la clause
dérogatoire générale activée en 2020 a
conduit à une suspension dé facto des
règles applicable devrait être désactivé
à la fin deanée
2023 la Commission a indiqué qu'elle
ouvrirait le cchant des procédures pour
déficit excessif dès le printemps 2024
et par conséquent les lois de finance et
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour 2024 sont importantes sont scruté
parce que ce sont les la première étape
qui doit conduire au respect de
engagements européens j'aurais dit ici
que je souhaite pour ma part que ces
règles soi réformé d'ici à la fin
d'année force de constater que le
gouvernement prévoit une progression
sensible des dépenses publiques en
2024 malgré une une sortie des crises
sanitair énergétiques et l'extintion des
mesures de soutien qu'ell ont suscité
les dépenses
continueront à augmenter davantage que
le recommandait l'Union européenne dans
le cadre du semestre européen en juin
dernier dans un contexte où la forte
progression de la charge d'intérêt
continue à croître les dépenses le
projet de loi de finan enfin contient
peu de mesures d'économie structurell
pourtant 2023 était le premier mésime
des revu de dépenses organisé pour cette
année que je salue d'ailleurs et le
projet de loi prévoit une quasi
stabilité du taux de PO il en résulte
une simple stabilité du ratio de dette
prévu alors même que la France voit sa
position d'endettement relatif au sein
de la zone euro se dégrader au cours des
dernières années je ne redis pas ce que
je vous ai déjà dit depuis 2020 même
avant le Conseil attire l'attention sur
le risque de la dette ce n'est plus un
risque 31 milliards de charge de la
dette annuelle en 2021 57 cette année 84
en 2027 ce sont les chiffres du
gouvernement un quasi triplement ça
devient le poste budgétaire progressif
c'est pas que budgétaire mais c'est
supérieur au poste budgétaire le plus
élevé de l'État c'est pourquoi le
Conseil continue mesdames et messieurs
les députés c'est son rôle appeler à la
plus grande vigilance quant à la
soutenabilité à moyen terme de nos
finances publiques voilà quelques
réflexions rapides j'espère je
souhaitais vous présenter je suis à
votre disposition pour répondre à vos
questions merci monsieur le
Président quelques réactions et
questions je m'abcenterai mais
j'écouterai votre
réponse bien évidemment par vidéo bon
déjà premier
constat vous le dites de nouveau vous
estimez que la prévision de croissance
pour
2024 reste élevée même si elle a été
baissée récemment par le gouvernement de
16 à 14 vous citer la Banque de France
0,9 les consensus d'économistes à plus
0,8 alors vous me direz et d'ailleurs
Bruno Bruno Le Maire le fait souvent on
pourrait arguer que les prévisions pour
2023 des mêmes économistes
était euh finalement plus pessimiste que
le résultat attendu fin 2023 sauf que
euh je considère que peut-être qu'une
des raisons euh de ce maintien de la
croissance en France si je compare par
exemple par rapport à l'Allemagne a
peut-être un rapport quand je dis
peut-être c'est par amabilité avec le
fait que nous sommes aussi euh un pays
où les dépenses publiques sont
importantes et que en période de reflux
et bien euh c'est plutôt positif pour
justement mainten une activité
économique ça l'a déjà été après la
crise des subprime en France et la
raison pour laquelle la France n'était
pas rentrée en récession à l'époque et
c'est peut-être aussi une des raisons
pour lesquelles cette situation est un
peu meilleur c'est d'ailleurs à mon avis
une des raisons d'un non dit que vous
précisez c'est-à-dire que on voit bien
que dans la loi de programmation des
finances publiques euh les baisses des
dépenses publiques dire pérenne et qui
ne repose pas uniquement sur la fin de
de dépenses conjoncturelles style
bouclier énergétique finalement on nous
les annonce pour 2025 bon à hauteur de
12 milliards don vous avez dit vous-même
qu'elle n'était pas documenté et on voit
et vous le dites qu'en
2024 le gouvernement se garde bien de
encore procéder à à une telle baisse bon
c'est peut-être le aussi le fait de
comprendre que quand on annonce une
quand qu il y a une récession en
Allemagne quand on annonce un reflux de
l'économie euh en Chine et bien c'est
peut-être pas le moment justement de
baisser les dépenses publiques mais on
ne le reconnaît pas et on essaie de
finalement de proposer une côte
maltaillée moi je crois que une des
raisons pour lesquelles malgré tout ce
cette croissance reste plus élevée dans
les chiffres prévus par le gouvernement
dans ce qui est annoncé vient peut-être
euh d'une mauvaise vision du pouvoir
d'achat des Français autrement dit ce
qu'on annonce souvent est en moyenne et
on et ne ne ne ne fait finalement
l'impasse sur les profondes inégalités
vis-à-vis du pouvoir d'achat dans notre
pays il y a une augmentation il se base
sur une augmentation de 1,8 % de la
consommation soutenue par une
augmentation de 1,3 % sauf qu'il y a une
terrible disparité des ménages depuis
fin 2021 la consommation en volume de
produits agricoles par exemple a baissé
10,2 % et celle de produits
agroalimentaires de 116 et évidemment ça
ne touche pas la population de la même
manière ce type d'inflation de même
l'augmentation du pouvoir d'achat
s'explique aussi par une plus for par
une forte hausse de celle des plus
riches notamment les plus riches qui
perçoivent des revenus du capital les
intérêts dividendes netes reçu par les
ménages ont augmenté ainsi de 4,2 % au
2e trimestre 2023 et le fait de de se
reposer sur des moyennes et bien
finalement fait que on on voit pas le
phénomène à l'œuvre et le FÉN à l'œuvre
c'est que la consommation populaire elle
est quand même très largement portée par
justement on va dire une grande partie
de nos concitoyens notamment ceux qui
n'ont pas ces moyens pour vivre et
ceux-là sont frappés par la crise c'est
ce qui explique à mon avis la distorsion
mais vous me direz ce que vous en pensez
de même la diminution du taux d'épargne
de 0,4 % euh je suis sceptique alors que
les Français ont commencé notamment les
français les plus populaires en tout cas
qui dispos quand même malgré tout une
petite épargne à faire à puiser dans
leur épargne pour faire face à la hausse
des prix enfin dernière remarque et vous
le dites d'ailleurs euh vous dites euh
que les dépenses rent s'avérrait plus
élevé que prévu notamment s'agissant du
coût des dispositif énergétique dépense
de santé d'ailleurs on vient de le voir
puisque en même temps qu'on annonce la
fin du bouclier énergétique le chef de
l'État euh annonce lui-même un chèque
carburant euh pour une grande partie des
Français donc c'est quelque part
reconnaître lui-même que l'inflation n'a
certainement pas cessé de sévir sur le
marché énergétique et peut-être
faudrait-il enfin comprendre aussi que
elle est désormais plus plus dû à la
question des marches des entreprises
qu'à la question de
l'organisation du du du du du
énergétique dans le monde voilà pour
toutes ces raisons je suis assez
d'accord avec votre prudence avec votre
avis et euh on prend date je pense que
le déficit sera plus élevé à la fin de 2
24 qu'il n'est annoncé aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement parce que la réalité
rattrapera ce budget voilà un petit peu
ce que je ce que je ressens à cette
heure mais on en reparlera cet
après-midi merci beaucoup monsieur le
rapporteur général Eton si vous voulez
bien prendre la place merci monsieur le
président madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup pour cette avis euh j'aurais
deux questions mais pr là permettez-moi
d'avoir un certain nombre de de de
remarques le premier c'est que nous
avons tenu le budget 2023 et dans dans
votre avis toutes les hypothèses 2023
sont considérées par vous comme
plausibles donc malgré un environnement
économique international
particulièrement difficile nous avons
ten nos objectifs en matière de dépenses
en matière de déficit et en matière de
croissance deuxème remarque c'est que le
budget que nous proposant est un budget
je crois de responsabilité
responsabilité sur la réduction des
déficits qui s'inscrit dans la
trajectoire que nous avons défini la loi
de programmation accélération
exceptionnelle de la transition
écologique et soutien des services
publics
prioritaires 3è remarque c'est
que pour
2024 nous anticipons à la fois une
baisse de l'in significative et vous
considérez
cette projection comme plausible et à la
fois une augmentation de la croissance
du PIB cette fois si vous considérez que
c'est optimiste mais quand même ça nous
fait penser que le plus dur est derrière
nous si je puis ainsi
m'exprimer alors j'ai quand on lit en
détail votre
avis on constate qu'il est balancé pour
reprendre une expression que nous avons
ont déjà eu lundi dernier euh entre les
avis plausibles les avis optimistes sur
la trajectoire et le budget que nous que
nous présentons moi monsieur Président
j'ai deux questions la première vous
vous nous dites que la prévision de
croissance celle qu'elle est prévu par
le gouvernement est est trop euh
optimiste et vous considérez en
particulier que nous avons une
anticipation trop important de la
progression de la consommation et et du
pouvoir d'achat des Français et pourtant
vous trouvez que euh l'estimation du
gouvernement du du taux d'épargne des
ménages est est élevé euh et considérez
qu'il pourrait être un petit peu plus
bas donc la question que j'ai euh quel
type de politique publique
pourrions-nous avoir pour euh faciliter
euh libérer euh l'épargne des ménages
2ème question vous considérez que le
niveau de dépenses publi anticipé en en
2024 par le gouvernement et est euh
sous-estimé euh en particulier avec le
risque sur la croissance
euh sur le coût du bouclier électricité
et un autre sur sur londam londam
précisait quand même que londam va
augmenter plus que l'inflation l'année
prochaine il faut quand même ici le le
le le rappeler de deux questions est-ce
que le moyen
de de d'éviter ou de minimiser le risque
sur le coût du bouclier est-ce que ce
n'est pas de
reconduire la taxation exceptionnelle
sur les profits des énergéticiens en
2024 est-ce que c'est une piste euh qui
pourrait nous aider et est-ce que vous
ne considérez pas que les mesures
exceptionnelles qui ont été prises par
le gouvernement pour assurer
l'atterrissage 2023 je pense en
particuliier à l'anéation des crédits
d'un montant de 5 milliards est-ce que
ces mesures là ne sont pas des gages de
sérieux pour la tenue de notre budget
2024 je vous
remercie merci monsieur le rapporteur
général monsieur le Président je vous
donne la parole pour répondre à cette
ces premières interventions
le le président cocrel a a livré une
certaine lecture de l'explication de la
résilience de l'économie française
relative en
2023 que je respecte
profondément je dirais simplement
que première chose personne en réalité
n'est en mesure d'expliquer ce qui s'est
passé sur deè trimestre 20123 personne
ce qu'on constate c'est qu'il y a un
train une tendance assez plate au
premier trimestre
qui ensuite ralenti au 3e 4e et il a un
phénomène 2e
trimestre dont ce livrait une
interprétation générale et systémique me
parait pour ma part audacieux je m'en
sens pas capable pourêtre tout à fait
franc je vis quand même par rapport au
remarque faitocrel souer que les mesures
de soutien on certes contribué à
préserver le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
mais que la consommation des ménages qui
a reculé en 2023 302 n'a pas été le
moteur de la croissance qui est plutôt
reposé
sur l'investissement et les exportation
donc peut-être il y a-t un phénomène
exportation alors certains parlent de
bateau de croisière en tout cas il y a
quelque chose qui s'est passé qui un
Isola à ce moment-là la France a été en
tout cas c'est peut-être une une
conséquence à structurel moins handicapé
que l'Allemagne par son exposition au
gaz russes et au marchés mondiaux et
donc tout ça ne me paraît pas en lien
direct avec la dépense c'est toujours de
bons motifs pour ne pas toucher la
dépense mais nous sommes restés quand
même en croissance positive j'ajoute
enfin que assimiler plus ou moins
implicitement les choix qui seraient
fait cette année à l'austérité n'aurait
pas grand sens je rappelle que notre
pays n'a pas voté un budget en équ
depuis 50 ans et que nonobstant les
choix qui sont faits là la dépense
continuera de croître c'est le cas dans
la plupart des départements ministériels
euh et que noustiendrons encore
55,9 % de dépenses publiques dans le PIB
si ça s'appelle de
l'austérité un petit chiffre quand même
par tête d'habitant la dépense publique
est de 28 % supérieur à ce qu'elle était
en
2000 la France ne sort pas vraiment de
20 années d'austérité elle n est
toujours pas entrée donc nous le
préconisons bien sûr en rien je suis un
peu embarrassé par vos questions
monsieur le
rapporteur général parce qu'au fond nous
convergeons je pense sur les analyses et
je pense qu'il faut toujours partir du
du langage du du hcfp jamais lui faire
dire ce qu'il ne dit pas on dit le
hcfp se base toujours sur les prévision
t qu'elles sont t qu'on lui donne au
fond celle du gouvernement et celle des
autres il fait un certain de
raisonnement économique il est pas là
pour faire des préconisations de
politique publi et il ne porte pas
d'ailleurs jugement sur ce que fait le
gouvernement il donne des des bases du
débat elles sont toujours objectives si
elles déplaisent c'est pas volontaire
c'est parce que ce sont des analyses
encore une fois d'un Sénat qui est très
pluraliste où les membres ont des
opinions extrêmement diverses sur le
spectre politique ou sur l'analyse
économique donc ce sont des ça doit être
pris comme tel comme un élément de débat
vous en en parz vraiment je je n'est pas
je pense c'est pas mon rôle que de dire
si telle ou telle mesure est est
jtif en revche je reviens quand même sur
un point sur la croissance élevé aussi
sur le déficit peu
optimiste
croissance de l' Buet prévision
àant en fonction des données don
dispose plus consensus c'est plus éev
que la Banque de France c'est é plus
tout le
M FA
il arrive que ce soit démenti ça été le
cas en 2023 c'est pas pour autant que la
prévision elle est erronée après on
constate que les résultats sont
meilleurs que prévus je le souhaite à
nouveau pour
2024 après on discute sur les mécanismes
économiques et là ce qui nous fait
penser que c'est élevé c'est pas
seulement c'est plus élevé que les
autres c'est que pour la totalité des
postes de demande consommation
investissement exploation le
gouvernement est plus optimiste que les
organismes par au conseil qu'il suppose
notamment que le durcissement des
conditions de crédit ça c'est le point
central à produit essentiel de Sév en
particulier sur l'investissement
desménage ce qui est une hypothèse
favorable et de ce point de vue là je ne
sais pas ce qu'il faut faire pour faire
baisser l'épargne mais ce que nous
disons peut pas exactement comme vou
c'est qu'en effet il nous semble que
l'hypothèse de baisse du taux départ
prévu par le gouvernement est optimiste
trop favorable et sans être basé sur des
comportements observables aujourd'hui
donc les question à poser c'est
peut-être justement comment est-ce que
vous faites euh je précise enfin pour
pour être tout à fait précis je je c'est
balancer salit nous ne disons pas que la
présision de croissance est tout
insincère irréaliste c'est atteignable
c'est pas hors de portée mais pour que
ça se produise il faut vraiment que
toutes les hypothèses très favorables se
cumule ça peut
arriver non mais c'est vrai et c'est
pour ça que nousous gardons de de
caricaturé nous le disons mais faut
quand même pas mal de
les planèes s'alignent sur sur le
déficit en effet nous avons estimé que
contenu de cela notamment mais pas
uniquement et en déficit et en dépenses
et en recette c'était c'était un peu
optimiste c'est pas non plus
inatteignable et nous n'avons pas
chiffré ce que serait le dépassement
d'ailleurs serait peut-être pas
considérable simplement j'observer 4,4
déjà par rapport à nos engagements
européen c'est pas extraordinaire c'est
un ralentissement du déficit qui serait
déjà assez faible si en plus on
dépassait on accumulerait encore d'où la
nécessité en effet d'être vigilant voilà
c'est ça le message du SCFP ni plus ni
moins merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président donc je vais donné la parole
aux différents orateurs des groupes pour
Renaissance Mathieu
Lefèvre ah pardon merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président nous
avons lu avec attention l' viis du au
Conseil des finances publ publ sur le
projet de loi de finan 2024 et moi j'y
lis une façon de de tordre le coup à de
nombreuses contrevérités qui circule sur
ce budget d'abord on nous dit que le
budget n'est pas sérieux le Haut Conseil
rappelle que les prévisions sont
plausibles
vraisemblables qu'il y a également de
nombreuses incertitudes dues à la
situation économique notamment
l'évolution de l'inflation qui rend les
prévisions difficiles donc merci a
travailler rigoureusement deuxièmement
on nous dit que le budget l'xiste il y a
une baisse du déficit dans ce budget une
stabilisation de la dette la France est
donc bien sur la route du rétablissement
des finances publiques un rétablissement
prudent pour ne pas casser la croissance
comme cela avait été le cas par le passé
on dit ensuite que ce budget incarne
l'austérité ou la casse sociale or les
dépenses d'administration de sécurité
sociale sont en hausse les pensions de
base revalorisé à plus de 5 % les
prestations familiales revalorisées à
près de 5 % une hausse de long d'â dans
quel pays avec des croissan une
croissance des dépenses sociales peut-on
parler d'austérité 4è nous dit
l'économie française s'effondre or le
gouvernement prévoit une croissance de
1,4 % en 2024 ce qui est mieux que
l'Allemagne et les États-Unis comme
c'est écrit dans dans la vie et c'est
bien le fruit de la politique économique
et fiscale que nous menons depuis 2017
pour terminer sur un sujet d'actualité
les collectivités locales là encore
l'avis montre que bien sûr il y a une
Haus des dépenses de fonctionnement
contrainte en raison de l'inflation et
de la revalorisation du point d'indice
mais la vie dit aussi clairement
que il y a une progression encore forte
de l'investissement des collectivités
territoriales et donc là à rebour une
fois de plus du discours ambiant qu'onon
peut entendre venant de certaines
associations
d'élus merci pour le rassemblement
national Jocelin
desessign non c'est Monsieur
cabrolier merci madame la Présidente
merci Monsieur Moscovici pour ce travail
on doit vous dire qu'effectivement on
partage vos inquiétudes sur les
différents indicateurs et ratios que que
vous présentez alors euh vous parlez
d'optimisme sur le solde public à 4,4 %
de de PIB euh je note que l'inflation à
2,6 % euh vous la trouvez crédible même
s'il y a un risque de dépassement
notamment par rapport au prix du pétrole
dont vous vous vous inquiétez inquiétude
également sur la hausse des taux
d'intérêts à juste titre euh qui font
vous venez de le rappeler que la
croissance à 1,4 % vous semble élevée et
en tout cas supérieure aux prévisions
des organisme et institut qui eux voient
une croissance entre 0,4 % et 0,9
% vous vous alarmez à juste titre de
l'augmentation des charges d'intérêts
plus 10 millions d'euros en 2024 et vous
avez rappelé hier que ça do aller faire
que le le montant des charges d'intérêts
allait être pratiquement le premier
budget de l'État euh de enfin pas dès
2024 mais bientôt devant celui de
l'éducation nationale alors j'ai deux
questions la première c'est la
Commission européenne a déclenché en
2020 la clause dérogatoire du pacte de
stabilité qui permet donc à la France de
s'écarter des exigences budgétaires et
on en a bénéficié en 2021 en 2022 et
certainement en 2023 mais il prend fin
en 2023 donc la question en 2024 avec la
fin de cette clause érogatoirees la
France risque de se voir déclencher euh
ce ce mécanisme de correction qu'en
pensez-vous et la deuxième question euh
concerne quelque chose dont vous ne
parlez absolument pas euh dans votre
rapport euh c'est l'impact de la crise
immobilière euh qui forcément va jouer
sur le BTP euh qui est très important
donc également que pensez-vous donc de
la de la la crise immobilière en
gestation merci merci beaucoup monsieur
cabolier pour la France insoumise
Sébastien
Rome merci Madame la président monsieur
le Président en fait si je traduis ce
que vous nous avez dit le gouvernement
joue un peu au 421 avec le budget 2024
donc c'est possible mais c'est c'est
peut-être pas
probable vous évoquez des prévisions de
croissance élevée optimiste dans un
contexte budgétaire d'austérité avec une
baisse de 16 milliards
d'euros est-ce que ce n'est pas de
nature à plomber l'économie sur la
question de l'épargne est-ce qu'une
action sur les salaires et sur des
salaires en hausse est-ce qu'elle ne
permettrait pas de débloquer cette cette
épargne ensuite je voudrais faire part
d'inquiétude d'abord celle sur la la
santé sur l'ONDAM avec j'entendais ce
matin la Fédération des directeurs
dehôpitaux qui malgré la haosse euh des
salaires de certains salaires dans
l'hôpital voit un manque à gagner de 5
milliards pour l'hôpital horizon 2027 et
donc une dégradation des conditions de
travail et du coup de la santé des des
Français est-ce que c'est vraiment
responsable enfin deux questions euh
comment estimez-vous le risque et je
rejoins ce qui a été dit juste avant que
fait courir à l'économie euh
l'amplification de la crise immobilière
et àin est-ce que les efforts
d'investissement dans la la transition
écologique sont en mesure de soutenir la
croissance et engager enfin la France
dans le respect de ses
engagements merci beaucoup pour les
républicains Fabien
difilippo merci Présidente c'est
toujours un moment très intéressant de
cette remise en perspective budgétaire à
l'approche de nos de nos débats sur le
projet de loi de finances nous avons
alerté y compris au cours des dernières
années y compris pendant le quoi qu'il
en coûte sur les conséquences que cela
pourrait avoir on est aujourd'hui dans
une évolution économique qui était
prévisible mais qui devient vertigineuse
et qui continue de nous de nous
inquiéter alors vous avez dressé un un
état des lieux assez précis avec quand
même un certain nombre de voyants qui
passent au rouge une situation
internationale avec des signes de
décrochage vous avez parlé de la
récession en Allemagne nous avons de
notre côté rencontré les président des
fédérations bancaires qui nous parle de
25 % de chute des encours de crédit une
chute de la consommation alimentaire sur
un an et demi quand même en volume de 12
% un orateur précédent a parlé de la
crise du logement et du bâtiment et
bientôt ça ira au-delà sur les autres
investissements donc on anticipe des
destructions d'emploi par centaines de
milliers et une charge de la dette qui
et bien nous expose à récolter les
fruits du quoi qu'il en coûte et qui
rendra impossible toute marge de
manœuvre c'est la conséquence logique
tout ça d'une inflation très élevée même
à deux chiffres sur les produits du
quotidien et vous de votre côté par
rapport trajectoire de redressement qu'à
qu'à émi gouvernement vous parlez d'un
manque de crédibilité de cette
trajectoire je cite vos propos que j'ai
vu dans la presse et des prévisions
optimistes sur la croissance notamment
pas pour 2023 mais 2024 et après et moi
je parle aussi de l' de l'évolution de
l'emploi salarié on voit que elle
s'effondre cette année et dans les
prévisions du gouvernement elle
rebondirait comme par magie à partir de
de l'année prochaine on est loin des
consensus économiques alors mes
questions j'ai bien entendu ce que vous
avez dit je sais que vous n mettez pas
d'avis politiqu maises deux questions
seront mathématiques le premier sur quel
montant réellement d'économie
supplémentaire devrait-on travailler dès
2023 ou 2024 pour contrôler l'évolution
des finances publiques et la charge de
la de la dette et deuxème question cette
charge de la dette financière qui sera
issue de la décennie Macron si l'on
corrige réellement les les les les les
hypothèses du gouvernement pour les
mettre sur le consensus est-ce qu'elle
franchira avant la fin du quinquena la
barre des 100 milliards d'euros annuels
ce qui en ferait le double du budget de
la dépense de la défense une fois et
demi le budget de l'Éducation nationale
je crois que dans la période actuelle
effectivement il faut de la transparence
une vision de long terme peut-être un
peu de courage
aussi merci beaucoup pour le groupe
démocrate
lail merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le président du Haut conseil je tiens
tout d'abord à saluer la lucidité de
votre évaluation quant à la robustesse
des bases sur lesqueles repose votre
projet notre projet de budget pour
2024 les indicateurs macroéconomiques
relatifs à l'inflation et la croissance
mis en avant dans ce texte démontrre une
fois encore la capacité de résilience et
de rebond de notre économie à la sortie
d'une période tumultueuse assurant ainsi
une croissance significative et un
contrôle rigoureux de l'inflation en
faveur de la protection de nos
concitoyens cependant vous avez exprimé
des réserves sur la prévision de
croissance du gouvernement fixé 1,4 %.
or cette anticipation se rapproche
sensiblement des projections avancées
par des institutions internationales
reconnues teles que le FMI et l'OCDE
vous évoquez une possible
sous-estimation des conséquences futur
du resserrement des conditions de crédit
pourriez-vous éclairer notre assemblée
sur les facteurs qui selon vous pourrait
entraîner dans les mois à venir un
impact plus prononcé de ce resserrement
sur les capacités d'investissement de
nos ménages d'autre part j'ai observé
avec intérêt vos remarques concernant
les recettes fiscales vous suggérez que
la croissance des recettes de l'impôt
sur le revenu pourrait être supérieure à
nos estimation
euh compte tenu de la vitalité des
prélèments à la source sur les sur les
revenus mobiliers serait-il possible de
bénéficier de vos éclaircissements sur
cette analyse enfin le gouvernement
anticipe une modération du tau d'éparne
des ménages à - 04 % hypothèse que vous
jugez peut-être optimiste quel pourrait
être à votre avis les conséquences sur
notre économie c'est ce taux d'épargne
venz à connaître une diminution plus
significative au cours de l'année 2024
je vous remercie par avance pour vos
réponses qui contribueront certainement
à enrichir notre
débat merci beaucoup pour le groupe
socialiste et apparenté Christine Pérez
bonne merci madame la Présidente merci
monsieur le président du Haut Conseil
pour cette présentation euh on a reçu
les éléments un petit peu avant cette
réunion de la commission des finances je
crois savoir que certains journalistes
l'ont eu eux encore plus tôt à 3h du
matin voilà petite remarque la prévision
de de croissance à 144 et loin au-dessus
du consensus à 0,8 quand il y a une
différence de 01 à 03 points
euh on peut voilà estimer que c'est ass
assz entre guillemets léger mais 0,6
c'est énorme et je m'étonne alors du
qualificatif employé par le Conseil haut
élevé qui me semble bien doux en
comparaison de de certains qualificatifs
employés il y a quelques quelques années
mais la question est la suivante
avez-vous simulé les effets sur les
autres variables macro-économiques et
sur les finances publiques si on
reconstruisait le budget avec 0
08 2è question la non reconduction en
2024 de la contribution sur la rente
inframarginale nous interroge le manque
à gagné pourrait être de 3 milliards
avez-vous interrogé le Gouvernement sur
ce choix avez-vous eu connaissance de la
contribution exceptionnelle sur les
raffineurs elle était chiffrée à 200
millions il semblerait qu'on soit plutôt
à 1 voire 1,2 milliards mais mais les
documents ne sont pas très clairs
euh dernier dernier point le rapport
confirmerait la la prévision de
croissance de la masse salariale autour
de 3,6 en 2024 elle pourrait-être
atteinte mais avec une croissance du
salaire moyen plus haute et de l'emploi
plus FAI or les politiques budgétaires
en matière d'emploi se justifient en
partie par la prévision de croissance de
l'emploi quel regard porte le ha conseil
sur la diminution des crédits àoués à la
mission travail de 600 millions d'euros
même chose en ce qui concerne la
diminution marquée des pactes régionaux
d'investissement dans lesquels l'État
investissait entre 2017 et 2015 15
milliards d'euros et qui devrait chuter
à 3,9 milliards n''y a-t-il pas un
risque à la suite d'une erreur de
prévision de poursuivre à terme une
politique dévastatrice pour l'emploi et
par extension pour la masse salariale je
vous remercie
oui merci Madame pierrezboun juste pour
préciser je pense que vous parliez de l'
l'envoi du PLF et non pas de l'envoi de
l'avis du Haut Conseil des finances oui
pardon du PLF bien sûr juste juste
préciser pour le groupe horizon et
apparenté Christophe
Passard merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président Pierre moscovicii
l'avis du Haut conseil aux finances
publiques relatif au projet de loi de
finan 2024 présenté en conseil de
ministre relève que les prévisions
macroéconomique du gouvernement sont
quoiquun peu optimistes quant au taux de
1,4 % de croissance pour 2024 malgré
tout plausible en ce qui concerne notre
taux
d'endettement la première question que
je vous poserai est relative à inflation
en regardant la situation à l'étranger
et plus particulièrement aux États-Unis
quelles sont les perspectives de la
France en ce qui concerne la sortie de
l'inflation pensez-vous que l'avancement
des négociations des prix de
l'alimentaire avec les industriels et
les distributeurs voulus par Bery
permettra d'endiguer d'amortir
d'accompagner le phénomène vous appelez
aussi notre vigilance quant à notre
niveau de de dette qui nous prive de
marge de manœuve suffisante pour faire
face à des chocs macro macro-économiques
d'envergure ou à une crise comme nous
avons pu en renconter en 2020 avec la
covid or nous sommes ici tous dans
l'attente d'une réévaluation de la
situation économique de la France par
les agences de notation qui arrivera
courant octobre soit en pleine
discussion du projet de loi de finances
puisquen matière budgétaire il vaut
mieux préparer le pire pour attendre le
meilleur je souhaiterais vous demander
quelles seraient les conséquences selon
vous d'une dégradation de la note de la
France d'une part pour nos prévisions
macroéconomiques et donc d'autre part
pour le contenu et les enjeux du PLF qui
nous sera présenté je vous remercie
merci beaucoup pour les écologistes
Christine arigi oui merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président le Haut
Conseil se montre très prudent sur les
projections gouvernementales la
prévision de croissance du gouvernement
pour l'année 2024 nous vous semble élevé
par rapport au consensus des économistes
et d'autres organismes et vous souignez
également un optimisme marqué du
gouvernement sur tous les postes de
demande y compris de consommation et
d'investissement s'agissant de la dette
publique vous rappelez l'importance de
sa soutenabilité à moyen terme pour
faire face à d'éventuels chocs
économiques ou financiers ainsi qu'au je
cite besoins élevés d'investissement
public en particulier pour la transition
écologique alors notre position rejoint
la vôtre monsieur le Président celle des
écologistes qui est clair il nous faut
des moyens supplémentaires notamment
pour le financement de la transition
écologique 13,9 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires dès le projet de boit de
finance 2024 pour les transports la
rénovation thermique des bâtiments les
énergies renouvelables l'agriculture
j'ai donc quelques questions à vous
poser votre avis sur les dépenses et la
dette publique prend-il suffisamment en
compte les avantages économiques je dis
bien économiqu puisque les écologiques
sont évidents les avantages économiques
potentiels de la transition écologique
sur nos finances publiques notamment en
terme de création d'emploi de croissance
et de résilience économique deuxème
question comment garantir la crédibilité
l'attractivité de la France tout en
retardant les investissements essentiels
pour l'avenir n'est-ce pas un risque que
nous ne pouvons pvons pas nous permettre
en face de prendre face à l'urgence
climatique quelle appréciation juridique
et comptable faites-vous de
l'augmentation sous-entendue du budget
vert de 33 à 40 milliards soutenu par la
majorité et le président de la
République lors de la première lecture
4e question lors de la première lecture
de la loi de programmation des finances
publiques le Haut Conseil avait soulevé
dans son avis une insuffisance
d'cumentation de la lutte contre la
fraude en ses mots l'effort de maîtrise
de la dépense et la hausse prévue de
certaines recettes inscrit dans la loi
de programmation ne sont que
partiellement documenté la situation
avec la loi de finan 2024 vous
semble-t-elle avoir évolué et le Haut
Conseil peut-il faire un suivi de son
avis sur ce point en particulier et que
pensez-vous enfin des propositions
visant à renforcer durablement les
effectif réellement et certains moyens
juridiques français et européens douan
dgfi pursaf pour lutter contre les
fraudes je vous remercie merci beaucoup
pour la Gauche démocrate et républicaine
je ne vois
personne pour liberté indépendant outre
maire et territoire Charles de
courourson président merci pour cet avis
copieux alors j'ai six questions très
rapides vous signalez page 19 que la
réforme des retraites en 2024 coûte aux
finances publiques 2 milliards 2 de
dépenses supplémentaires pour 2
milliards d'économie mais est-ce que
dans ces chiffres que vous indiquez vous
avez tenu compte de l'incidence sur
l'Unedic et les finances départementales
essentiellement le RSA deè question vous
signalez que le déficit structurel dans
les prévisions gouvernementales ne
baisse en 2024 que de 04.s de PIB alors
que l'Union européenne dans le pacte de
stabilité demandait à tous ceux qui
étaient au-dessus de 60 % de PIB de
dette publique de le porter à 0,5 donc
est-ce que pour vous il y a un risque
que la France fasse l'objet d'une une
procédure pour déficit excessif
pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur
l'hypothèse gouvernementale de baisse du
taux d'épargne qui est très élevé est-ce
que ceci est crédible à votre avis à
travers les indicateurs
qualitatif 4e question la baisse de la
productivité vous avez fait un
développement très intéressant de
comparer l'évolution de la productivité
du travail en France et dans les autres
pays européens qui montre l'anomalie
française comment vous interprétez cela
et est-ce que il n'y a pas un risque
pour l'emploi c'est dire un redressement
de la productivité parce qu'on voit pas
comment la productivité pourrait
continuer à à baisser et puis deux
dernières
questions sur
l'incidence du prix du baril de pétrole
puisque il est actuellement plus élevé
que celle des prévisions
gouvernementales quelle est la
sensibilité notamment de la croissance
et de l'indice des prix et puis dernière
question troublante vous signalez que la
croissance de la TVA est supérieure à
celle de sa base taxable donc comment ce
peut s'expliquer un tel phénomène où
est-ce que c'est tout simplement parce
qu'il n'y a plus que 100 milliards de
TVA sur le budget de l'État alors que
son produit est de 200 milliards et que
donc c'est la sécurité sociale et les
collectivités territoriales qui en
prennent une part
croissante merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président je vous donne la parole suite
ces différentes interventions des
orateurs de
groupe vous êtes en fait déjà entré dans
le dans la discussion sur le PLF ce qui
est normal c'est votre rôle groupe
politique beaucoup de questions
auquelles comme comme responsable public
que je fus ou comme citoyen je pourrais
avoir telle ou telle opinion mais comme
président conseil des finances publques
je me garderai de répondre je
mentionnerai notamment le fait que nous
sommes pas là pour évoquer les scén
alternatif nous saurions faire mais
c'est pas dans notre mission donc nous
le faisons pas simplement peut-être
quelques remarques générales d'abord sur
sur
l'inflation pour rappeler simplement que
nous avons jugé que la prévision
d'inflation du gouvernement ét plosible
avec des Res de dépassement notamment
lié à l'évolution récente du prix du
baril la
prinationtionverement basé sur un prix
bar légèrement inférieur à ce qu'il est
aujourd'hui donc certitude très forte
aussi ça suppose que une régulation sur
les prixalimentaire c'est en cours
jusqu'au ila cela ça reste à
préciser sur le taux d'épargne ça c'est
une une donnée qui en effet vu comme en
baisse par le gouvernement il faudra
poser la question au ministres nous nous
avons estimé que nous ne savions pas
l'expliquer et donc dès lors ça nous
paraissait plutôt quelque chose de
favorable sur la productivité euh il y a
quelques explications possibles l'effet
de l'apprentissage la rétention de main
d'œuvre dans dans dans l'énergie euh une
hausse de la productivité serait
peut-être à court terme dépable l'emploi
mais favorable la croissance à long
terme et donc aux finances publiques ce
qui serait une bonne chose sur les 16
milliards monsieur le député comme
politique d'austérité non dans la mesure
où ces 16 milliards en réalité sont pour
l'essentiel
non structurel et repose sur le retrait
de dispositifs qui eux-mêmes sont liés à
l'évolution des prix deénergie donc
c'est pas quelque chose qui est euh qui
a un impact sur sur la
croissance sur les retraites je vous
invite à demander directement au
gouvernement le calcul de ce coût de 2,2
milliards d'euros à ma connaissance il
n'exclut pas il n'inclut pas les effets
de la réforme sur les retraites des
retraite sur le RSA en particulier
euh voilà pour quelques remarques
générales en ajoutant que la lutte
contre la fraude qui a été mentionné ne
figure plus dans les mesures évoquées
par le gouvernement en 2024 comme pour
la suite et donc c'est pas un facteur
d'ajustement des finances publiques dans
les documents du gouvernement tels
qu'ils sont mais là aussi ça mérite
peut-être de poser la question un ordre
de grandeur quand même je pas parler de
sur alternative mais des calculs de
coins de table qu'on peut faire
si nous étions sur 0,8 points de
croissance ça représenterait 0,3 points
de déficit supplémentaire donc quand
nous disons que le la prévision est
élevée c'est pas sans impact bien sûr
sur le déficit ça veut dire que si on
est sur 09 ou 08 il faut trouver 03
points de P supplémentaire et et donc ça
renvoie soit à des Hauses de prélèvement
soit à des baisses supplémentaires de
dépenses soit une augmentation du
déficit à 4,7 qui pour le coup serait
vraiment très élevé au regard de nos
engagements européens et poserait des
problèmes pour la trajectoire future
donc voilà
euh que une fois dit cela un de vous a
dit que le gouvernement jouit 421 c'est
pas notre sentiment nous avons le
sentiment que il y a un Paris derilleurs
tout ça d'un certain nombre de
comportements économiques vertueux qui
aboutissent à une prévision
élevée que l'observation et les
prévisions aujourd'hui ne laissent pas
en effet présagé comme probable mais qui
ne sont pas impossiblebles
et on vous objectera bien sûr les
résultats de l'an dernier qui à notre
sens ne sont pas totalement expliqués et
ne sont pas forcément reproductible mais
c'est à vous ensuite d'avoir ce débat
avec le Gouvernement sur ce
Paris sur la compatibilité du PLF 2024
avec les règles européennes la
commission européne a annoncé que la CLA
dérogatoire générale du P serait
désactivée à la finée 2023
été activée en 2020 elle a conduit une
suspension de facto des règles
applicables
la Commission a indiqué qu'elle ouvrira
des procédures pour déficit excessif dès
le prés 2024 sur la base des résultats
de 2023 et comme vous savez en 2023 et
2024 le sol public demeure sensiblement
supérieur à la limite des trois points
de PIB l'amélioration du sol structurel
quand elle demeure inférieur et
également sensiement aux exigences du
volet préventif du PACT de stabilité de
croissance et de sur quoi les dépenses
continuent à progresser sensiblement
2024 davantage que recommandé par
l'Union européenne
conclusion
je préfère nêement que les règles soient
réformées et qu'on ait une appréciation
plus en tendance et nationale des
profils de dette publi je dis toutefois
que ça signifie aussi que notre position
relative au sein de la zone euro ne
s'améliore pas
ehémisme et que à notre sens un effort
plus grand serait nécessaire pour ce qui
est de l'impact de la crise immobilière
plusieurs d'entre vous l'ont évoqué la
vie aussi par ses conséquences sur
l'investissement des ménages
en baisse en 2023 2024 baisse
sous-estimée à notre sens en 2024 par le
gouvernement et par les recettes de DMTO
en chute de près de 20 % 2023 stable
dans la prévision du gouvernement en
2024 ce qui paraît optimiste souhaitable
mais optimiste donc oui là l'ampleur de
la crise immobilière assurément peut
jouer un rôle sur la suite quand à
l'investissement écologique les 7
milliards de dépenses supplémentaires
dans le budget 2024 sont prévu l'impact
sur la croissance il est incertain si on
suit le rapport pan fer mafous qui ne
dit pas que c'est forcément positif pour
la croissance il est pris en compte dans
le la trajectoire du gouvernement mais
attention aux effets
indirects de la dépense publique sur la
dette et sur la charge d'intérêt tout
cela doit être apprécié et je Redi que
le rapport pisiffous considère que
l'impact de la transition écologique
pourrait être plutôt défavorable à court
terme à la croissance donc c'est un
investissement qui aussi coûte euh
sur voilà je crois que j'ai à peu près
fait le tour de des questions qui m'ont
été posées questions nouvelles le reste
encore une fois soit j'ai déjà donné la
réponse soit je j'estime qu'il n'est pas
de mon rôle de m'engager dans un débat
politique qui est clairement en revanche
dans votre mission ni de commenter les
opinions des uns et des autres puisquil
y a pas toujours eu des questions très
bien merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président effectivement nous comprenons
tout à fait votre rôle là euh nous
allons passer au au aux autres orateurs
et en premier lieu je voudrais moi
réagir sur le le niveau des prélèvements
obligatoires dont vous avez parlé avec
une croissance spontanée de 3 %. je je
suis assez dubitatif sur cette
croissance j'en veux pour preuve le
tableau de bord du gouvernement de
Juillet 2023 je n'ai pas regardé ce
matin si le tableau de bord de août
était publié mais le tableau de bord de
juillet 2023 3 laisse euh présente un
impôt des recettes en matière d'impôt
sur le revenu qui ont diminué de 5 % par
rapport au niveau de juillet 2022 des
recettes d'impôts sur les sociétés qui
ont diminué de 14,8 % par rapport à
juillet 2022 des recettes TICPE qui ont
diminué de 7,7 % et donc des recettes
fiscales qui globalement à périmètre
courant ont diminué de 7,7 %. voilà donc
effectivement est-ce que cette
croissance spontanée de de 3 % a
aujourd'hui paraît cohérente au regard
de ce qui se passe je vais ensuite
donner la parole à Patrick
edzel voilà Monsieur edzel Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE oui un micro voilà oui ça y est
c'est fait merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Président merci
pour cette cette analyse très très
précise vous avez il y a quelques
instants mention
le fait que la Commission et vous
connaissez bien cette institution avait
annoncé que la
clause en fait dérogatoire du PACT de
stabilité de croissance serait désactivé
à la fin de l'année
2023 l'une des hypothèses à ce moment-là
c'est de considérer que à partir du
moment où cette clause est
désactivée cela pourrait avoir des
conséquences sur le spread et donc la
question est assez simple est-ce que du
côté du hautceil des finances publiques
vous avez un petit peu regarder euh euh
cette situation là puisque en réalité
euh vu euh les finances publque
française on pourrait quand même se
retrouver avec un spread qui augmente
c'est-à-dire des taux d'intérêt euh qui
euh serait plus important euh pour la
France que pour d'autres pays de l'Union
européenne ce qui en réalité pourrait
enclencher une une spirale problématique
pour le pays donc voilà ma question
porte là-dessus quelle incidence
potentielle sur le spread est-ce que le
ha conseil des finances publiques s'est
intéressé à cette question pour 2024
évidemment je vous
remercie merci beaucoup Mathieu
Lefèvre merci Madame la la
Présidente je reviens sur ce qu'a dit
Monsieur de con sur la réforme des
retraites l'AVE évoque
l'impact négatif pour les finances
publiques à raison de la revalorisation
des des petites pensions je voulais
savoir si le Haut Conseil avait pu
décliner les impacts en matière de
consommation notamment qu'enorter à la
revalorisation des petites pensions pas
seulement sur les années 2023 et 2024
mais sur les années ultérieures et
deuxièmement vous évoquer le le le
dynamisme de la dépense des
administrations de sécurité sociale qui
est pour partie lié au mécanisme
d'indexation indexation des retraites
indexation des des prestations
j'aimerais savoir quelle est la part
dans l'augmentation totale de la
dépenses publiques de ce mécanisme
d'indexation qui représente je crois en
montant global de l'ordre de 25
milliards d'euros donc de l'ordre d'un
point de
PIB merci Fabrice
brun merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Président en ce début de marathon
budgétaire je reprendrai à mon compte
une devise du Haut Conseil comment
obtenir de meilleurs résultats sans
forcément dépenser plus mais en
dépensant mieux donc ma question c'est
est-ce que oui ou non à vos yeux ce PLF
2024 atteint cet objectif sachant qu'en
2024 l'État se prépare à emprunter un
montant record sur les marchés et que
Bercy parie toute à la fois sur une
hypothèse de croissance et sur une forte
décru de l'inflation que beaucoup jugent
optimistes et même analyse que mon
collègue Etzel sur l'évolution des taux
d'intérêts merci Jean-Philippe
Tangui merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président première chose je
je suis désolé on est plusieurs à ne pas
avoir compris votre réponse sur le
mécanisme de correction européen et
deuxième question plus générale pour les
prochain une loi de finance est-ce que
vous avez un avis sur le fait qu'il y a
le aujourd'hui le prix de le le prix du
baril de pétrole pardon qui est dans les
hypothèses macro-économique de de de
d'anticipation du projet de loi de
finance est-ce qu'il ne faudrait pas
ajouter en fait le prix de l'électricité
et peut-être même le prix du gaz puisque
c'était auparavant deux indicateurs qui
étaient historiquement stables pour la
France qui malheureusement ne le sont
plus et on l'a vu ces deux dernières
années qui ont des incidences sur la
bonne tenue du PLF et les les recettes
et les dépenses qui sont plus que
conséquent je vous remercie merci je
n'ai plus d'autres orateurs inscrits je
voudrais juste vérifier donc c'est bien
le cas monsieur le Président vous avez
la parole je vais commencer par par par
l'Europe sur des question été posées
d'abord avec une remarque qui est que le
spread est très stable depuis un an
alors que les marchés savent que la
clause dérogatoire générale sera levée
en 2024 donc il y a quand même une
anticipation en la matière par ailleurs
j'ai dit qu'on faisait pas l'hypothèse
j'ai pas répondu tout à l'heure à la
question sur les agences de notation ce
n vient pas de d'intégrer ça dans nos
perspectives en revanche ce qui est vrai
sur le mécanisme de correction européen
comme vous dites c'est que la clause
drogatoire qui a été activé en 2020 qui
a dèslors suspendu les règles des facto
devrait être levé le 1er janvier 2024 et
qu'à ce moment-là la Commission
européenne non seulement je la connais
la commission mais je connais ce
portefeuille qui fut
va examiner l'éventualité de procédures
pour déficit excessif pour un certain
nombre de pays et à cet égard le fait
que euh bah tout ce que j'ai souligné
c'est-à-dire une prévision un peu élevée
des dépenses qui ne baissent pas des des
des résultats en teres de déficit qui
peuvent être optimistes et qui sont
élevés euh ça peut être considéré donc
euh la discussion avec la Commission
européenne la Commission européenne
n'était pas à mon époque elle n'est pas
davantage aujourd'hui stupide ou bornée
donc elle est flexible on peut pas
penser que c'est c'est boom c'est pas un
coup près ça n'a pas été pendant 5 ans
je me suis efforcé j'ai réussi de ne
sanctionner personne en revanche les
tendances sont une discussion et donc
évidemment la crédibilité de la
trajectoire et la LPFP en particulier
c'est les éléments de discussion avec la
Commission Européenne j'ai dit par
ailleurs que les règles telles qu'elles
étaient ne me paraissent pas
satisfaisantes et que je préférais
qu'elles soit réformée pour être plus
intelligente ça c'est à l'Eurogroupe à
l'écophine voir au Conseil européen de
le décider dans les semaines qui
viennent j'espère que pon est plus
claire
désormais je crois qu'elle ENF difficile
qu'elle le soit beaucoup plus quand on
connaît ces sujets sur sur les prél
obligatoiresad député en effet nous
estimons que les prés de PO sont plusi
pour 2023 et qu'elles sont plutôt
favorables pour
2024 notamment du fait d'une hypothèse
de croissance d'activité optimiste et
aussi d'hypothèses favorables sur le
rendement de certains impôts vous enz
certain n sur MTO les cotisations
sociales donc oui nous mentionnons cela
comme un des facteurs favorables en
terme de recette qui qui font que nous
estimons que la présent déficit est
peut-être un peu optimiste
euh sur et et la présision du
gouvernement prend en compte les
résultats des recettes fiscales bien sûr
[Musique]
sur les crois que les questions de
Monsieur Leff sont adressé plus
directement au gouvernement qu'à nous
qui pourra détailler ces trpres
hypothèses davantage que nous n'avons le
moyen de le
faire question monsieur
BR je narrive plus à me
relire pas plus c'est une question que
j'ai
oublié monsieur
brin monsieur brin est- que vous pouvez
juste rappeler la question monsieur le
Président voudrait vous répondre
oui juste
oui merci monsieur le Président je
retournais à mon compte votre devise
comment obtenir de meilleurs résultats
sans forcément dépenser plus ou mais en
dépensant mieux est-ce que l'objectif
est atteint avec ce PLF monsieur le
Président je
oui non écoutez ça c'est une
appréciation politique que vous aurez à
ce que nous pensons en tout cas et ce
sera mon message final c'est qu'on peut
dépenser beaucoup mieux et nous
considérons que il y a des progrès qu' y
a eu un changement méthode et un
changement de volonté c'est sûr qu' le
budget que vous examinez n'a pas le même
cap on finit enfin le quoi qu' en coûte
ça fait longtemps que nous l'appelons
nos vux et il y a une volonté
d'équilibrer les choses avec des
dépenses qui sont comm dépenses de 16
milliards nous constatons que ces
dépenses sont plus liées au retrait
certains dispositifs que les dépenses
structurelles nous pensons que pour
l'avenir ce sera plus dur je sais plus
lequel d'entre vous a dit le pire est
derrière nous bon en terme budgétaire en
tout cas le plus difficile le plus
difficile est devant nous le plus
difficile devant nous et devant vous en
particulier parce que 16 milliards dont
3 et structurel ok mais l'année
prochaine c'est 12 milliards pérenes
qu'il faudra trouver là l'exercice devra
être un peu différent c'est soyonsen
tous conscients et ce que je dis c'est
que là effectivement la lev du Haut
Conseil et de la Cour des comptes c'est
tu penser mieux meilleure qualité de
dépense
publique les r dépens publi je les ai
salué je pense qu' se tient encore pour
le moment un peu en vase clos entre
certaines inspections et certaines
administrations je pense qu'ell ne
prennent pas en compte la totalité de la
dépense et il faudra aller beaucoup plus
loin c'est-à-dire prendre en compte
investissement et fonctionnement toutes
les dépense état colog sécurité sociale
avoir un débat sur le sujet qui soit
beaucoup plus ouvert et démocratique qui
inclut le Parlement et peut-être des
institutions comme la Cour des comptes
qui est bien sûr
disposé et enfin que ce soit fait dans
la durée et pas réservé à une saison
particulière la saison budgétaire parce
que quand il trouver 12 milliards
d'euros Pen par an il faut quand même
changer de braquet et changer de méthode
je sais pas si ça répond à votre
question donc voilà on a fait les
efforts cette année il y a un changement
de cas un début d'orientation de méthode
que je salue il faut aller à notre sens
et au mieux en particulier beaucoup
beaucoup plus loin sur ce je vous
souhaite une discussion budgétaire qui
sera passionnante à nen pas douter et
que j'espère
fructueuse en rappelant mon message qui
est que nous avons besoin d'e
programmation de finances publi j'espère
qu'on m' entendu sur ce sujet merci
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
pour nous avoir éclairé sont toujours
des des avis et des éclairages très
intéressant merci à vous